head over to the best song ever.com and
purchase our new hit together again it
is a cover of smokey Mike in the god
king that's Jeremy boring and Michael
nolles and with your help we will smash
our way onto the Billboard charts
Christian former military officer
beheads satanic Shrine in Iowa state
capital the world may tell Christians to
submissively accept the legit
legitimization of Satan but none of the
founders would have considered
government sanction of satanic alars
inside capital buildings as protected by
the First Amendment uh I
disagree I I actually I half agree I do
think that there were there were
obscenity laws and there were moral
standards and as much as the founding
fathers did believe in free speech I
still think they would have been morally
outraged at the idea of a SAT satanic
Altar and at that point I think
Constitution wouldn't even have mattered
back then today it's a different story
but here's the story Michael Cassidy a
Christian and former military officer
Tor down and beheaded the Satan wter in
the Iowa capital on Thursday we're now
learning that Turning Point USA is
pledging $10,000 to the legal fund of
Michael Cassidy Christian veteran who
beheaded s satanic Idol in Iowa state
capital well I'm going to ask Luke what
he thinks first cuz he's the he's the
anarchist over here yeah same thing is
it confirmed satanic listen there's a
lot of demon worshippers inside of the
government that's a fact now do you have
freedom of of religion do you have
freedom of of speech and expression I
think so as as well and I think we we
have to understand that there's a
delicate kind of uh line that we have to
go down here as of course we still got
to respect people's individuals Liberty
uh but let's call out the Satanist as
well U you don't have to resort to to
BLM tactics in order to kind of express
your opinion was it actually satanic or
was it has Baff and this the tenant of
Satanism and all that stuff and uh you
know I I am not a fan of Satanism I am
not ignorant to Satanism I read their
tenants I understand what they're saying
I'm not a fan of it I also think Luke
get the nail that with hammer you
shouldn't resort to BLM tactics don't
legitimize the thing the left the things
that left does do when they don't want
to go through the proper procedure and
policy I think the challenge here would
be to counter it through the system
because we want to maintain stability
and Order and in fact I'd argue this is
the exact response the left was hoping
for yeah I mean I'm a free I mean I'm a
a constitutional absolutist I do believe
every religion should like if we can't
accept satanic even though I don't
accept satanic people I don't think
there's anything valid in what they
believe but I have to respect the fact
that this is their religion then one day
you know what what could happen if
Christianity is abandoned that I don't
think that that's far off from happening
so unfortunately we have to kind of
accept the beliefs of these people and I
guess their statue that they had there
was in response to something like I
think that there was a a monument of the
Ten Commandments and then they wanted to
put the satanic statue up to say there
they want their freedom of religion yeah
listen most government bureaucrats are
secret demons if they're open out in the
open overt demons yeah tell me more
about it I want to know that that you're
a demon um and and attacking it again if
if the shoe was on the other foot if
this was a Satanist attacking a a
Christian symbol people would have a
very different reaction than they are
right now kind of complimenting this but
I do want to stress this Satanism is not
necessarily the worship of Satan and I
think it's important we can go through
what was actually on that altar cuz I'll
tell you this right now woke people in
this country are not satanists according
to the satanic temple and the people who
are with the satanic temple do not
actually follow their own tenants such
as the first one should strive to act
with compassion and empathy toward all
creatures in accordance with reason well
we know for a fact they don't do that I
mean you don't go go go around smashing
uh buildings smashing Windows starting
fires and attacking people that's not
compassion the struggle for justice is
an ongoing anary Pursuit that should
never Prevail over laws and and
institutions that's funny they've
captured the institutions and used laws
to destroy the lives of people during
the mandates and the lockdowns so it
doesn't seem like they follow that
tenant one's body is inviable subject to
one's own will alone now that one really
gets me going right there what does that
mean one's one's body is inviable what
is that it means that no one can uh uh
penetrate your body nobody can interfere
with your body yeah huh ain't that a
good one this like chaotic liian or
something what happened to that one
three years ago freedoms of others
should be respected they threw that out
the window including the freedom to
offend yeah they threw that out the
window to willfully and just unjustly
encroach on the freedoms of others to
forgo uh one's own beliefs should
conform to One's best scientific
understanding of the world wow they
really threw that one out the window
people are fallible they they threw that
out the window when it came to fouchy
that's for sure if one makes a mistake
one should do One's best to rectify it
every tenant is a guiding principle
designed to inspire nobility and action
and thought the spirit of compassion
wisdom and Justice should always Prevail
over the written or spoken word you see
it sounds s like it's a chaotic religion
uh like D and D it's not lawful it's not
because it's like good and righteousness
should Prevail Over Law and Orders I'll
tell I'll tell you what it comes off to
me it's people who are secular atheists
who created a religion for the sake of a
position in religious arguments they use
Satan specifically as a way to insult
and offend the majority religion in the
country in the world Christianity and
then they make what many people would
find to be reasonable statements as a
means of convincing you Satan is good is
it Lucifer is that the same thing I
believe Lucifer was like the angel of
Light and like knowledge so I think I
believe they're different but I don't
know enough about we have freedom of
religion in this country and people
could believe whatever they want to
believe in if they want to believe in
some like meatball pineapple thing in
the sky go ahead we have the right here
in America to do this some politicians
don't believe in that personal Liberty
uh including individuals like Ronda
santis that talked about this very
specific issue saying that he wouldn't
allow it and he doesn't view this as a
legitimate religion just because you
don't recognize a religion doesn't mean
it's a it's not a religion for it is a
religion forl I it's not my religion I
disagree with it I think a lot of the
tenants should be called out especially
within the government but using
government Force to go after people's
religion is something that I am
absolutely alergic to in verse two think
about the tenants I read where they say
something like your body is subject to
your own will freedom should be
respected respect act don't don't
distort science all these things they
want you to agree with these things as a
reasonable
and then say see isn't Satan good right
that's that's the game they're playing
these tenants have nothing to do with
what Satan represents they're trying to
it's it's it's like cult uh cult
building they will present you something
very reasonable like hey would you like
to join our club we serve pizza on
Fridays and you're like wow I would love
to come to a pizza party then when you
show up they lock the doors and start
preaching about Satan like Satan is it
the devil I think they they try to use
Satan as an analogy or you know it's for
knowledge and and Science and and
finding the truth and and Justice like
say like you know to to uh not it's a
it's a way to just like I don't know
like question authority to question
authority to to not fall I guess for
like other religions that you know
morality I don't know I mean I I I'm
going to look into it though but you
know like I do believe that it's
something that has to be protected
though Ronda Sanders was asked about
this in Iowa and he said it was Trump's
fault because it was a trump
Administration officially recognized the
the the satanic temple as a religion and
he said I would he said he wouldn't do
it right Luke he I know that he said he
said uh the Trump Administration gave
them approval to be under the IRS as a
religion it it very well may be because
of that ruling under Donald Trump that
they may have had the legal leg to stand
on my view is that it's not a religion
quote Ronda santz and he said more than
that he said not not a religion the
founding fathers what were trying to
create well that's subjective and I the
founding fathers weren't trying to
create religion right and I think it's
danger I mean I Rona santis is my second
choice but after Trump but I think a lot
of the things he says are dangerous when
it comes to speech and when it comes to
religion like these type of things I
don't think it's fair to Define
someone's religion really I don't as
much as as abhor it is just the same way
with speech like you know people used to
say I'll defend your right to say
whatever you want Even though though I
think it's disgusting nowadays that's
completely not the way it is anymore so
I do feel like we have to defend
religions that are horrible like
Satanism I'm assuming and terrible
speech you know people the ACLU used to
protect the KKK the clu clux plan this
this is multiculturalism and this is why
it don't work is it is this in a
political building was it worth is it
righteous for people to put up religious
icons in political buildings no and they
shouldn't have done it so the the the
Ten Commandments is the mistake here is
the one the Ten Commandments going up
was like the thing that set this off
they wanted to sort of counter to
counter the Commandments there is no
reality in which a righteous Christian
person will tolerate satanic imagery
being put in their buildings and at the
same time secular atheists and woke
cultists will not tolerate Christian
Christian governance yes so
multiculturalism it it it won't work he
said quote I saw this Blasphemous statue
and was outraged my conscience is held
captive to the word of God not to
bureaucratic decree and so I acted I
mean I could see myself doing that I I
know that sounds terrible like people
have bad tempers but like if I saw a
satanic statue I mean I would have to
pay pay the price if you know get
arrested probably pay a fine and maybe
even go to jail but like you know people
become infuriated when they see that
type of thing if I saw a satanic statue
in a government building I might chop
this head off that's the attitude of BLM
right and I'm it's an emotional attitude
and but I'm not saying that I wouldn't
be subject to the law then that then I
wouldn't be arrested or or have to pay a
fine and you know face the public
there's value to being calm in in the
face of being taunted because this was
obviously someone was trying to taunt
somebody with this and uh it worked yeah
James Lindsay had retweeted something
earlier about this uh someone made a
meme video the left uses this tactic of
mid-level violence we've talked about it
a bit it's the I'm not touching you
tactic they they showed a video where a
woman was sprinkling glitter on
conservatives heads and the cop came up
to her and said you've just committed
assault if you do it again you'll be
removed and she goes I didn't touch them
right well you don't need to touch
someone to commit assault uh depending
on the jurisdiction but this is the game
they play attempting to provoke a
reaction from you so that you look like
the aggressor and look unreasonable well
it's a very real my response with that
to that was very simple I'm like if
someone sprinkles something over you
just start gagging and fall down and
then throw up and say that they they M
you or something like that's the soccer
tactic if exactly play play the soccer
game if they're going to sprinkle
something on you then you need to
overreact like they're trying to do
something so minimal to you that when
you react you give the escalation and
your escalation creates the appearance
sprinkling glitter on most people goes
unnoticed you swatting their hand away
now looks like you struck them for no
reason you're like and you fall down and
then your friend goes he's allergic man
he's allergic to aluminum dioxide what
are you what are you doing man and then
call the police they poisoned him they
poisoned him all of a sudden now
everyone's like whoa what happened like
that lady was spraying with something
you got to play soccer with these people
because they're trying to play soccer
with you so when they put the satanic
imagery in the capital smacking it is
exactly what they wanted right now
they're going to come out and they're
going to make a bunch of propaganda
based off of it they're going to say
that the right is intolerant doesn't
respect Free Speech they're going to say
the right doesn't respect the First
Amendment they're going to say things
like they never believed in free speech
in the first place Etc ET this sounds
like half a story what happened to the
Ten Commandments thing that started it
all off well that's not a part of the
story so I don't know I wonder if they
tore that down and or maybe it's a
different area tough to say well what
you said about you know the left doing
this stuff like for example in when I'm
sometimes reporting in New York they do
this thing where they put their umbrella
in front of your camera and the police
can't do anything about it the police
like they're not not touching you or
they'll just put they'll take umbrellas
and put in front of your face so you
can't see and then if you push it away
you could get in trouble and it's like
this you got to play soccer it's
infuriating it is you have to really sit
there and just like calm your temper
down because you just want to take the
umbrella and break it but then you're
breaking someone's property even though
they're Maring you that's what they're
trying to get you to do nonphysical
interference is is interesting if
someone held up an umbrella it's you
know what I use the Frasier example it's
an old classic episode of Frasier so uh
Fraser crane is enjoying a nice uh uh
cup of coffee in his favorite seat at
his local cafe he's in a rather bad mood
and he gets up to go get stirrers or
something and when he comes back there's
a man sitting in his chair he's fed up
he had a bad day he says sir you're
sitting in my seat the guy tells him to
screw off Frasier gets mad picks the guy
up and throws him out that guy files
charges and sues Frasier for assault and
battery and now Frasier's in trouble
it's going to cost him a ton of money
what do I do at the end of the episode
he confronts the guy and Niles Frasier's
brother walks up and says you listen
here you're suing my brother and you're
in the wrong the guy filing the lawsuit
then says no you listen to me and pokes
his chest and then Niles goes whoa and
falls over and smashes into a table and
he goes counter suit counter suit thus
ending the whole thing and the guy's
like I didn't I didn't I didn't do
anything to them they're like we saw you
you hit him you hit him and he fell down
that's the game they're trying to play
with you the problem is people on the
right are so Noble and honorable they're
like I I I won't do that the left knows
that the right is trying to play fair
and so they know they can play dirty
better example Jack pic gets punched in
public on camera the police witness it
happen and pull up antifa says no it
didn't it didn't happen I didn't see
anything happen what are you talking
about lying fortunately the police
watched it happen and arrested the guy
but that's the game they're playing with
you so I don't think God I don't think
that God cares about iconography like if
you're in a room surrounded by evil
looking satanic imagery and you stay
calm God will be pleased that is what
you're supposed to do you're not
supposed to to freak out in the eyes of
like being taunted perhaps but uh Thou
shalt not have false false Idols is I
believe that's one of the Commandments
which one is that like second one yeah I
thought that was number two it is a
second commandment but then false Idols
could be anything it could be a lot of
people say the Catholic saints are false
Idols I mean I'm Catholic but I'm just
saying that's what people say like
Saints are false Idols I think if you
worship a human that that is a false
idol personally like we're not supposed
to worship people that makes no sense
that's that's why I get edgy about Jesus
like the people worship Jesus I think
it's a false idol yeah but you can
Revere people for their Good Deeds I
agree but worship God but but
acknowledge that humans I mean to say
that Jesus is God it's that that is a
Christian Bel that Jesus is God that's
what I believe and I am named for uh St
Timothy and do you know what he is the
saint of oh yeah good digestion yes
that's right St St Timothy is the patron
saint of gastrointestinal distress I
love the Saints I think they're super
legit like I when you when you're having
gut problems you pray to sa I would
think Jesus is a saint like I would
consider him Saint Jesus instead of
worrying about in the Christian religion
he's the son of God who died on the
cross to you know make Man live forever
so he's more than God I mean he is God
human ination of God thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 pm and become a member
over at timcast.net